hello, how are you, greets héctor mejía
with his brief informative for today,
wednesday, march 3, we start with
news in development this morning
, a fire was reported in a
condominium complex about management and exaggerates the
officers who were the first to
arrive to evacuate 18  departments
no injuries were reported, however three
vehicles caught fire due to
this incident for the moment
the cause is unknown
cis students are no longer
attending school campuses today
this day will be used to disinfect and
prepare the classrooms for the group  b
which begins tomorrow they will ensure a
deep cleaning in each school to
avoid any contagion of the virus
what is the marketing command and duties
all return to their operations as
of today the three properties closed at
midweek several months ago
however in  james works tells us that this
decision had been made to
reduce cases of the coronavirus and e  Waiting
for more people to visit the city now
more employees will return since they will be
working all week
and now we turn to the weather forecast
we will see a cloudy sky with some
breezes in the southwest of the valley there is a
chance of showers for the afternoon
however it will be a  hot day
around 70 degrees have a nice
day I am hector mejía and this was your
brief design brief in spanish